hey guys and welcome back to reality
check now I've been kind of doing a
miniseries within the show where I've
been taking a look at how games are made
you might remember we covered things
like streaming and a couple of pieces of
middleware this week I'm taking a look
at something that's pretty key in video
games physics now before you click away
I know physics usually fills people with
dread myself included when it comes to
video games physics is genuinely quite
an interesting subject because it's
physics that helps games be games
there's two types of physics engines
first there's your high-precision engine
which uses a lot of processing power in
order to calculate really precise
physics they're a bit over-the-top for
what we need in video games so
developers typically use a real-time
physics engine where the calculations
are less processor intensive and are
therefore more appropriate for the needs
of the game so effectively what we're
getting is a rough simulation of
physical systems physics that are
perceptually correct rather than being a
hundred percent accurate thinking back
to last week I talked about middleware
software that's integrated into game
engines to perform specific tasks now
there are quite a few pieces of
middleware that have specialized to
tackle physics there's the two big
players the Nvidia owned physics and
then this havoc I can almost guarantee
you've played a game that utilizes one
of their physics engines like half-life
2 for example sources in built physics
engine was derived from havoc we can
think physics in games like Arkham
Knight and attack of the cloth and
destruction of The Witcher 3
there's also bullet a physics library
that's been used extensively by Rockstar
to give physics to games like GTA and
Red Dead Redemption
there's also engines that are great at
destruction like digital molecular
matter which is being used in quantum
break so TLDR there are loads and they
all have really important jobs like
interaction so objects in games interact
with loads of things they interact with
the player character the environment and
of course other objects an important job
of a physics engine is to detect these
collisions a function that's helpfully
known as collision detection here's how
it works
the
final character model that you see on
screen is not what the engine sees to
the engines I this model is covered by a
low detail skin known as a collision
mesh or collision hull by using this
less intricate mesh the engine is able
to quickly work out the appropriate
response for when two objects collide a
more intricate mesh would result in a
bigger and more CPU intensive
calculation which obviously isn't ideal
with all of the other stuff that the CPU
has to figure out if the collision
detection in a game isn't great you'll
get what's known as a clipping issue
which is where one texture or model
unrealistically passes through another
small clipping issues aren't typically
gang breaking but they do look weird now
bear with me here there are two types of
these collisions one that uses rigid
body physics which is not as sexy as it
sounds and the other that uses soft body
physics now rigid body refers to the
movement and interaction of solid
objects those that won't deform under
physical forces like when a bowling ball
hits the floor it would of course remain
rigid because it wouldn't be a good
bowling ball otherwise this kind of
physics is less CPU intensive to figure
out because the shape remains the same
soft body physics on the other hand is
way more complicated and therefore more
taxing on the CPU it means that the
object is susceptible to bending or
breaking based on the physical forces
placed upon it take a look at soft body
physics in action in this video from
beam and gene realistic disruption based
on the crashing of the vehicle that just
simply wouldn't be possible if the car
was just programmed in as being
completely solid so let's talk a little
bit about death because why not a not in
a morbid way but because the reason
death animations have gone from stiff
prescribed movements of your two unique
animations that change within the
context of the game is totally down to
advancements in physics engines creating
death animations used to involve
manually creating each one these so
called canned animations weren't very
CPU intensive as they just required the
game to pull on a pre drawn set of
frames but with increased computational
power it became possible to procedurally
generate death animations where bodies
would conform to physical forces and
you'd get a different animation each
time depending on the situation nowadays
what we usually get is a mix of cans and
procedurally generated animation the
death looks realistic but is kept from
going over the top well unless your
saints row that is a great example is
rockstars use
of the euphoria physics engine developed
by natural motion it stimulates the
motor nervous system body and muscles
and procedurally generates natural
looking reactions so the animations are
both appropriate and unique to what
you're doing we typically only notice
game physics when they go spectacularly
wrong let's celebrate all the stuff that
they do right so remember a bunch of
really smart people have built amazingly
complex software that's all for you just
so you can do things like this so that's
just a quick look at some of the awesome
things that physics engines are
responsible for in video games now next
week is of course III so there'll be
some more reality check in a couple of
weeks thanks watching and I'll see you
then